yeah okay we're garyvee zip it instantly
I know patience is the key put enough on
my ship for free
this is tea we carry feet Michael make a
friend this is tea with guarantee and I
am garyvee hope everybody super well I'm
fired up it is April 17th feeling
energized by the all-in challenge where
we at right now all-in challenge I
expect everybody who gets 7.4 million
dollars raised in the first three days
at the all-in challenge I'm super
flattered super excited super humbled by
all the support from everybody in this
community and Dustin do we have a tidy
URL or garyvee URL for my öland
challenge I want to get that get the
team to do that
Gary be calm / all in a challenge and
then we can put that down here because I
want everybody who's watching Dustin
doesn't you said yesterday that you
bought raffle tickets to have Gary the
experience I did oh crap
Justin I'm a little bit worried right
now cuz it's because I know it's been so
crazy for our whole team because we've
all been on this did you make it so that
when this episode ends it ends with the
end of it my man I'm proud of you Thanks
get me an orange guest good morning good
morning good morning for an oz door
what's good what's good dr. Neil 1973
Rachel que Cara link good to see you
Gregory Millard what's good what's good
hi Gary
how are you good how are you I'm well
moving him what's going on how you
figured out works my question for you is
how do I make a consistent monthly
income as a motivational speaker author
blogger youtuber because right now I
make I would say 95% of my money
one-on-one sessions I speak to teenagers
so I'm not sure I think of how I can
make money doing speaking gigs I think
what you can do if they're speaking 101
to teenagers
if that's your framework I think you
should start
a monthly Club for parents of teenagers
where the club gets a video each week
from you on things you've learn from
talking to teenagers and each of them
get invited to a close your two-hour
live session with you every month so
it's group sessions group sessions so
you can scale and original content
exclusive for that group it's 1999 forty
nine eighty nine dollars a month I think
and then you start marking towards that
and now all of a sudden you have a
thousand people paying you eighty nine
dollars a month you be nine thousand
dollars a month in recurring revenue
your make you're making a million
dollars in revenue on the back of twenty
four hours a month of group sessions and
four videos a month and I think for a
lot of parents with anxiety of like what
to do with their teenagers if I made
that business tomorrow I'd probably make
ten million dollars a year yeah I love
it oh my god No thank you so much have a
great day
Thank You Dustin that's how you do it
get on here I just want to talk about
that first call because that that that's
real [ __ ] right there honestly wasn't
paying attention
agent gizelle what's good what's good
Kevin Anthony morning Brad Eric you know
what's funny when he says give it away
for free
Eric what's interesting is she was
asking how to make revenue how do you
build the biggest brand how do you make
the most revenue that is around free and
what would happen next Eric by the way
who just brought up I saw you're gonna
say give it away for free is that she
will put out a ton of content for free
but then for people that want something
even more detailed where you know and
then even more access it's there right
and so you can give away a lot of free
but but giving away for free forever and
not building a business model is you
know
a vulnerability for some you know I
don't like when people package up and
make it $997 ebook with just
regurgitated stuff you can find for free
but when you layer a one hour meaningful
video where you really go through [ __ ]
and and it's unique every week and you
give them two hours of your time once a
month now you're starting to add to
value and in micro payments 90 bucks or
less a month you know you can you know
for somebody who's a parent with anxiety
of their teenager that let's quote let's
say she decides to go thirty bucks a
month or three hundred sixty dollars a
year for 52 weeks worth of what our
videos and for 24 hours worth of access
time where maybe three times you get
your question asked like this comes
valuable and it's about being proud and
feeling valuable about what you sell
this is fun this is the show is
exploding let's keep it going King sees
what's good Brandon Brandon no man's
gonna see you good man they got you I'm
so like you I speak for a living and
it's my life so with everything that's
been going on my business has been
absolutely annihilated
nobody's booking and everything that I
had has either been cancelled or pushed
back for months so my machine and by the
way Brandon right away you better assume
all of those that are pushed back have
been cancelled I know last night was
telling their parents you know and I
make a lot of money speaking I was like
this year's shot to zero and next year I
think is gonna be twenty percent of what
it would be well I'm sorry to say that
but I want you to have the best but I
could be wrong but I think until there's
a vaccine you know think about it if
it's January there's no vaccine and
you're the kind of company that puts on
a conference and you would put it on in
March you're not gonna do that and so
you're gonna wait and let's say comes in
April of May then they're gonna be like
okay [ __ ] it do we do in November
December it's good you know so brand
listen you really have to strategize
right now and that's why we're here you
were gonna have to make the assumption
that this year and next year are gone oh
by the way you and I are massively
did but so is Lady Gaga and Bruno Mars
and Drake people to understand how much
money is made an actual stuff of that
nature so it's live nation this is a
very challenging time for people that
draw people together yeah
you know so I have a mission to elevate
empathy and I want to push people to
become the greatest version of
themselves so with that being said I
would love to know in your opinion what
other possibilities you think that I
should explore and kind of where to go
from here I if I didn't run vaynermedia
I would be living on the Internet right
now I'd be alive I'd be doing T with
Karen be you know lunch with Gary be
cocktails with Gary be dinner with Gary
Vee late-night drinks with Gary Vee and
I'm not kidding I would prop if I did
not run if I was you if I was just Gary
Vee not Gary Vaynerchuk which is what
I'm 90% tub but if I was just Gary be I
would be on the internet 12 to 20 hours
not would I be on 12 to 15 hours a day
doing QA like this Wow okay if your if
your mission is to elevate empathy in
the world you can do it more this way
than you can do speaking it's so true
and obviously the opportunities that are
coming out of this are so great and so
much more substantial than you're
exactly right those speaking gigs of
those stages now thus pinky because our
our gigs are more financially free full
right now yeah my hope and dream is that
you've saved some money can kind of
weathered a storm if you didn't and you
overextended yourself you're gonna now
need to convert dollars from the
internet which is gonna let you put you
in a tricky spot because the second you
charge for it you can't build as much
scale I'm so grateful knock on wood that
I that I'm doing tea I mean right now
a stunning percentage of my audience is
saying tea with Gary Vee is the single
best thing I've ever done for them
quality wise yeah and I'm grateful that
I can do it for free
and by the way if I was just Gary Vee
and didn't have all the diversity of
everything I do I probably would have
been they would have not been able to do
all of it for free maybe I would do ten
hours for free
and then probably or I would take
donations okay well you know you listen
patreon yeah like you know or or you
know like or build my own little
execution truth is because I haven't
looked at donations I'm not even sure of
the donation infrastructure but if you
look at China you know we're gonna see
that happen here in the US with Tik Tok
and things of that nature
you're gonna see every case Instagram
live is gonna have a donations button
for you while you're on live I believe
that to be true
so you know definitely for nonprofits
but I mean for you tips tips tip jar
like like just like somebody you're
playing the piano or or someone in the
street like that's real talk like I
think I think I would if I if I did tea
with Gary Vee for 12 hours a day and it
was free but there was a tip jar I have
a funny [ __ ] feeling you know I said
this the other day of how much would you
pay for this and bunch of people
answered in the comments I'm gonna ask
this question hey everybody who's
watching right now if I was doing this
right now twelve hours a day how often
would you tip if would you tip at all
and they it's a zero for some people
game they're not [ __ ] tipping and how
much would you tip leave a comment I
think it'd be interesting so I think
brain that's where you need to think
about okay build Brandt
listen Brandon when when there's times
like this it's time to build brand what
everybody's doing is trying to make
sales right got it
absolutely man so much love three thank
you take care yourself yeah there you go
Facebook this is how little I look at
the tip infrastructure Facebook right
now has its tip jar that's right I
actually didn't know that so yeah maybe
we should put it up we should maybe I
will put it up [ __ ] it take the money
and do some garage sale and buy some
sports cards alright let's keep it going
shouldn't like do that just for the data
Gary does oh one second Dustin take a
look at what's going on with the with
the Facebook tip infrastructure let's
get Mike bank account all set up like
let's talk to any and Jim I just want to
guys if I do this tomorrow we're soon
I'm gonna don't I got a figure I want to
do it for the data
I like doing it okay we'll pick it up
right know what's good Gary what's up
man
well uh awesome thank you so much for
having me on so I just kind of get into
it I
I am a pasta manufacturer right outside
Philadelphia one is for ten years yes
sir um so as I said in my when I was
talking with Dustin is we've had a lot
of I started from nothing so nothing to
you know we're you know we're doing
pretty well here I've taken my lumps in
you know retail stores distributor stuff
like that so we're at a place right now
where we had really good customer
engagement we're getting some nice
inquiries over the internet but I know
for a fact my product is really is
really good but let's just [ __ ] pasta
it's me okay um I also know that my
marketing is just not worth the quality
so yep
delicious [ __ ] pasta and [ __ ]
marketing hundred percent okay um I know
and honestly I've been doing this for
ten years and the last couple years I've
been really looking at myself and like
not giving myself [ __ ] of like I'm
doing a good job you're doing this now I
I'm like at the point where I'm like you
know what no not doing a good job
yeah so for you yeah so so my question
is you know I I think I sell to too many
people we have a wholesale business that
we sell to we also that's b2b and then
we have our b2c that we have direct
consumer
and I'm I feel like I'm caught in
between both of them and I'm not giving
either or not yeah yeah well first and
foremost you 100% want your dtc business
to get your ABCDE effort even though
your b2b business is where your business
is right because that's like my bread
and butter that's why I weekly my like
my restaurants well not right now my
restaurants but that's your that's you
but that's your vulnerability your
vulnerability is that you're making your
money in the thing that isn't your
future and that's where you're getting
caught okay
okay so from a from a focus standpoint
not necessarily dollars but especially
right now more than ever right ii like
if i'm you based on everything I just
heard I'm 100 I'm spending 18 to 20
hours a day cuz you're young you can you
can pull a couple four hours I did last
night had clonked out at 11 because I
was dead so I got a nice little seven
eight actually I needed it because
before is [ __ ] me up I need five I
need six really to do my thing I can get
away with five without being dead but
fours [ __ ] me but you need to be [ __ ]
going crazy on Pinterest crazy I'm
running a ten dollar Adam in Swedish
swipe ups to see if it works you you
need to you need to build your b2c
business not restaurants not retailers
because the way to build a healthy
business is to have your business be
amortized over 15,000 people that buy
your pasta not 12 right right yeah cuz I
mean as it right now we're going crazy
with the virus I mean every like we're
really busy right now which is why those
down so thankful I'm dry pasta because
no one can get it and and so are you
selling it to consumers well it's all of
our online markets that sell like we're
on Amazon and we're and we're going it
we're gonna order better yeah 400
percent more than what we usually get
which is great I'm so thankful for that
but Amazon then becomes the middleman to
I want you to build your own
infrastructure to sell direct to
consumer okay so and that's so that's
perfect so be saying that because I
guess that was like that's that's what I
the justification I needed because we
want to do a fresh pepper pasta deliver
to your door we're about to launch
something at Bainer you should email me
I don't know if you're gonna be able to
afford it but we're about to we're
trying to create a low product blueprint
in our commerce capabilities because I'm
getting emailed 40,000 times a day I'm
trying to I'm trying to figure out so
because I love small business I'm like
okay if I take my assets and I move them
to this product and it's a fifteen
dollar fifteen thousand dollar blueprint
and I sell a bunch of those because I
can get the four million dollars from
one client like I'm trying to figure it
out I'd like to do both right now it's
chaotic and I don't have so many people
that actually know what they're doing
but that's what you need you need to
figure out that world okay yeah and then
it's like there's like I'm
real quick real quick everybody wants to
buy your pasta so what's the name of the
pasta and is it on the Amazon it is on
Amazon hold on watch this you're about
to self so much [ __ ] pasta bro
it's called bare pasta con Oh so but
it's I'm Amazon because that's gonna be
easy for everybody what is it v ve RN e
yep P asta didn't just [ __ ] spell
pasta for me bro I did brother still so
is it called pot as a pasta vera vera
pasta it sounds different pasta yeah I
should have a crap bag on there so wait
a minute there's a ton of pasta birra
are those [ __ ] are you pissed to
those guys because people get confused
sometimes yeah I tried I tried to t
heaven and and and and they wouldn't let
me because pastas too general so oh wait
I see it now very pasta it's got like
the big red very caustic oh yes all
right my man let me see here
appreciate it they were pasta penne my
man the 3-pack is $24.99 mm-hmm crying
huh damn shit's another go ham for you
bro I appreciate one one last question I
want the more time um I I loved what you
do as far as like you are the brand and
you're giving back you're giving people
content and stuff like that and I want
to be like an authority in the Italian
food pasta so main content there you go
okay what you do yeah whatever you're
about to say would you do the answer is
yes the difference between me and a lot
of people is any time I say would I do I
do it because of two core things one
humility one to sub confidence the
humility to not value my time at my
level at my level to go and do it for a
month and have it fail that's humility I
don't my time everybody here is like
valuing their time when they're timing
work [ __ ] and to the confidence that it
[ __ ] sucks that my dad my brother my
best friend the world is like you
[ __ ] failed I'm like yeah yeah you're
supposed to micro fail yeah I've had
that a lot of them you're supposed to
microfi I know the only the only thing
you can make fun of me
or as if I go out of business if I don't
[ __ ] you I'm supposed to be micro
failing I'm making fun of you for
[ __ ] thinking about [ __ ] I'm doing
out here I'm [ __ ] doing out here
hundred percent would I yes [ __ ]
yes Mara pasta pas ta I would [ __ ] do
it make sure let's go awesome by the way
your website crashed fix that [ __ ]
I wasn't joking your website crashed
[Laughter]
Dustin we need that whole video chopped
Prince around especially the way it
ended that was for grace thank you
speaking of a website that won't crash
you know where I'm going dust and give
it to me okay listen to me
yesterday a good chunk of you signed up
but I'm [ __ ] pissed
people are keyboard warriors talk about
how much they're gonna donate to me and
they buy wine do not by the way it cost
money to send a text is not email so do
not sign up for why text if you don't
buy wine do not sign up for wine text if
you buy wine not if you don't buy wine
at least once a month but I'm telling
you with all my heart and I need to see
the comments for a verification that you
just did it and I need you to go to
Twitter I need you to literally do it
while I'm we're watching this right now
and go to Twitter and signup screen
shoot the confirmation that you signed
up for wine text and then go to Twitter
Gary B here's my screen if you buy wine
once a month at the store at wine calm
at Total Wine at the supermarket Publix
Albertsons at Costco at [ __ ] Trader
Joe's if you buy wine if you buy one
once a month if you buy one once a month
and you [ __ ] are not signed up for
wine text you're [ __ ] breaking my
dad's heart America only there's about
seven to ten sites we can't a state some
can't ship - I'm sorry illinois's I'm
sorry Michigan I'm sorry Texas but Utah
but I'm telling you if if you're 21 and
older see the fifteen or if you'd like
me in any way can you take the URL of
wine text and post on your Linkedin your
Twitter your Facebook and say you should
sign up for this it's an
aníbal service because it is because it
is cuz it's [ __ ] crazy
today's deity give me a preview for
today's deal my [ __ ] phone has been
like cuz it is I want to see who's
signing up no Canada Canada people
you've got to buy empathy wines empathy
wines Canada just type that in empathy
wines Canada today's is either gonna be
either gonna be a $45 [ __ ] a $45
Chardonnay for 1937 a bottle 93 points
or a 94 point Pinot Noir that's 60 bucks
for 2888 actually in the comments say if
actually you're gonna control it today
teen with care of you type in pasta like
jesus [ __ ] christ type in white pun
type in Chardonnay or Pinot Noir in the
comments tell me which one I should do
and definitely sign up the wine tax
[ __ ] because you can sign your mom up
I mean you got you should get her
approval you need her credit card when
you sign up so you know okay let's keep
it going and who signed up for it Paige
hi I knew I'm good how are you good okay
well I actually just all the sudden got
super nervous so don't be okay so I had
an original question and I kind of have
this thing of like dealing with things
myself so I watched a bunch of your
videos pretty much answered my own first
question and I came up with them so if
you you see I'd apologize page on the
decide to do something Colton Lewin I'm
retweeting your sign up
I'm retweeting I'm retweet Louise I'm
retweeting yours as well I'm gonna
retweet these screenshots like cuz I
want people to people
get some love - all right Paige go ahead
I'm into where you're going okay so um
if you kind of like manifest your own
thoughts and you put out what you want
to receive kind of deal how do you
balance between your losses and your
wins posting them on social media or
putting that out there because some
people think like the whole two steps
forward one step back and you want to
see the whole process but how do you
balance that out because you don't want
to constantly post all the negative
things that happen well I think micro-
is great right I know I just wrote that
down your micro loss your micro failing
right so what are you scared of that
you're like debbie downer if you're
constantly posting or do you want it or
do you want these people to be convinced
that you're good because you need them
to convert into something because that
would make sense to me that's not a bad
thing I'm just trying to understand the
question
so um not really a conversion I'm really
big into like health and wellness so
actually I apologize real quick so cuz I
want to share this mm-hmm
I I bought an je bead with like four
different publishing sites and music and
sports and lost millions of dollars when
I was building vaynermedia which taught
me to buy pure Wow and that's why 137
and people are doing well cuz I lost
money buying lost Letterman and other
things like that and I mean there was a
deal I made for a great music's I don't
even own a [ __ ] name six years ago I
bought like 50% of it and then we didn't
do as much as I thought we would and we
gave and then I gave all the equity back
to the person just how to write off
600,000 okay so it's just a it's just
your own your own balance your own life
I guess is is what it comes down to and
and age I think people are starting to
push back against people on Instagram
who just show glam yeah no for sure it's
highly annoying and how how do you
balance it you just [ __ ] balance it
like some months you'll be 38 percent
negative and 62 percent positive and
other times it'll be the reverse okay
talk okay well I'm really nervous guys
like this don't miss amazing so like one
of the big things that I had an issue
with was posting I'm I'm really good
with typing things out and I'm very
passionate about people and I want to
help people and I just felt like every
time I wrote something with a little
picture I was getting a lot of negative
feedback like why are you doing this
that you're an idiot this is not cool
like you're asking for donations for
people to who are already working like I
did a health care package care packages
for health care workers and I was doing
a fundraiser for that and like you were
getting really mad at me and it what did
they want you to do I don't know and I
didn't want to like I don't know cuz I
didn't really ask them they were just
kind of yelling at me about how
collecting money for people who are
working is a terrible decision right now
and you know I need to be thinking about
myself and other people and you know
people who don't have jobs and so in it
you're telling me that you were taking
donations to help frontline
care takers during this pandemic yes and
you were keeping none of the money yes
okay Paige listen to me when people are
hurting they project right now 22
million Americans have lost her job in
four weeks from 2010 to 2020 during an
economic explosion we we created twenty
two million jobs so in the last ten
years up to this pandemic we had one of
the great economic runs in American
history and all the jobs that were
created during that time have vanished
in four weeks so what's happening Paige
is this has nothing to do with you
you're overanalyzing you what's
happening is the people that are saying
that are either one of the people that
lost our jobs or is the loved one of
somebody lost their jobs so right now
because it's so easy to hide behind a
keyboard people are projecting their
anger so here
why everything I've been talking about
for the last three years about
self-esteem and strength is gonna play
out even more now because the people on
the front lines of creating content
whether for themselves to make money
because they also have to live or
anything is gonna require self-esteem
now that doesn't mean that people aren't
toned up you have very wealthy people
putting out content that is upsetting
people mm-hmm and cuz that's tone-deaf
but what you just explained to me is a
wildly nice act of you taking your time
and efforts to try to help the people
that are helping us the most and what
what I'm worried about is that you're
over valuing the comments when you're a
hundred percent right okay wow that was
a whole weight lifted off of me
but I don't want you to take my
validation for it either the red came
off because you value my validation and
so now that countered the anonymous
validation so you feel better I want you
to not value my validation I want you to
not value their validation I want you to
live with inside yourself okay the
reason I'm gonna win this whole thing is
nobody lives in a more quiet place on
earth than me there could be people that
are tied with me but my [ __ ] is quiet as
[ __ ]
nice here's the key to get there thank
Camp you're welcome you can't feel great
when you get positive validation the
reason the reason I think I'm the reason
now I'm confident that I can win this
thing
meaning be happy and make impact and
have a good life is coz now that I'm at
a hot moment where my brand is exploded
I've got validation coming from the
highest levels in the world Fame
politics money like just I'm in it right
I don't believe that either I don't
think I'm special
so when somebody says you're pretty or
you're smart or that's a great idea you
can't get high yeah you got to stay
quiet in the middle because when
somebody comes and says you're a piece
of [ __ ] you've already practiced for
that moment and you over value
compliments people that tear you down
have leveraged nice that's a that's
pretty heavy Gary you know but it's the
game you know what's great about this
format is I'm not rushed in the office
I've got more time I can articulate like
I'm going to step deeper in my thoughts
saying the same thing I've said before
but in a different way this that that
two minutes might be the most impactful
thing I've said for a far majority my
audience it's a big deal and my my
happiness is predicated by humility okay
that's super cool it's awesome
happy to help you thank you so much Airi
talk to you bye let's keep it going
you show what's good Gary how you doing
man
really well this is wild this this is
part of like my whole thing of like
being the luckiest person in the world
like literally I've been in deep end of
Gary Vee I've known about you for years
but like in the deep end of the pool for
like three months
you know I told my friends I might help
what happened how do you know what the
piece of content was that I'm in the
shallow a local park I love I love
podcasts and I go for like a morning run
every morning and you know you just kind
of light me up and kind of like I like
your energy so it kind of gets me going
so but have you get into the person I'm
like learning like what made you like
one day you were like oh yeah I kind of
know this dude I'm a little oh just
listen in one podcast hit and then oh
it's like yes I mean I listen to a lot
of different podcasts and I like the
fact that you put out every day so
there's new new content cuz like I'll
listen to
money but it's like once a week in
psycho right now
you know there's 800 podcasts already
all of them so we're with you it's kind
of like every day there's something new
and like even for the 15 minutes that I
run I don't run that much like that far
but you know I'm saying I know go ahead
brother so you were telling your friends
yeah I'm telling them like hey I'm about
to talk to Gary they're like how'd you
land that I'm like I texted him you know
like there's been you know there's the
number like yeah I did it like 10 times
but like it is what it is you know so I
just kind of but it's part of my luck so
like to kind of set up my two-part
question is like I was lucky to grow up
in Ukraine until I was 12
like bulwark um because that you know I
grew up outside of the bubble of us and
people don't get a lot of that like its
sac what - when I came here let me let
me help everybody
as a former Soviet boy - when he when
he's saying it's sad everybody who's
watching right now we're in the middle
of a pandemic there's we just lost 22
million jobs and the structure of
America is still such an uncomfortable
level of opportunity compared to where
me and this man come from and most
people come from it is grossly
underrated and so are the other great
democracies in the world no matter what
iteration they're in right now keep
going um so I like when we when we came
here here I was 12 and like 13 14 got
right into construction because we have
to help the builders and of course yeah
so I grew up really quick just working
with you know 50 60 old Ukrainians and
just kind of going at it so that was and
those blogs are dirty those dog early
you know we're doing roofing and you're
like hold my hands so it's kind of like
a lot of that stuff so I got to learn a
lot in the trade and all that then -
like I like business and I think my
parents are amazing my family is amazing
and like they kind of instilled in me
like I can do it you know a lot of that
um so in my whole course anybody who's
got optimism and you can do it thinks
they're lucky I knew that from the
second you open your first mouth the
first ones out of your mouth I'm like oh
this guy's optimistic
like i see- even to this situation today
on my thirst there's gonna be positive
out of all of this to me uncomfortable
levels of positive there's enormous
amounts of people that are gonna lose
wealth for take health off the equation
anybody who loses somebody they care
about doing this pandemic it's
devastating
yeah comma in the framework of that
we're talking about business there's
gonna be plenty people that lose money
there's about to be people that are
gonna make an enormous amount of money
there's so much opportunity I mean and
also think about like people that we
will save down the road 20 years from
now because now we're not naive that you
know we're gonna do German games and
things like that like we're gonna start
thinking about like what could kill an
economy versus you know like a war or
whatever but yeah so okay besides that
like I my whole life like I've kind of
been chasing like I believe that I have
like greatness inside of me like I don't
know like it's not know that's like
naive or is that but you know like I'm
like everything is so simple these days
it's like I could go for a car ride with
a friend of mine and I'm like you know
we have this idea it's like dude we
should start a business I'm like let's
do it this weekend you know let's let's
get the website going we can like it and
it's always it's so simple these days
it's almost for me as a person it's hard
that it's so simple cuz like I can kind
of lose my focus a lot so so but but
don't don't judge yourself so what all
you have to do is not make a big creep
make a big statement when you start
don't tell everybody like the way you
protect yourself from being unfocused
and stopping and starting is don't make
a big statement that you're gonna change
the world with this app stay quiet for
the first year instead of what most
people that are optimistic like you and
me do which is the second they do
something like this is gonna [ __ ] in and
then three weeks in they change your
[ __ ] mind I got [ __ ] I just taught
and you can be the boy that cries wolf
so stop [ __ ] crying
yeah so here I'm going though I do I I
get it I do like you know I should shut
my mouth a little more and just I don't
know well I know who you are because I'm
listening that's why I just gave you
that advice good news you have an idea
start on Saturday you change your mind
on Thursday because I got [ __ ] this
you're set because he didn't tell your
mom your dad your best
friends that this you're gonna [ __ ]
bees Mark Zuckerberg yeah
show your [ __ ] mouth so kind of to
setup my question is like I I was lucky
that I felt like I got married super
early and I had kids super early but
then at the same time I had my first son
he's three now I started a business and
I went like all in deep into the
business cuz I was like hey man I might
get this going
within the next 3-4 years like I'll be
freaking retired and I'll just focus on
my kids you know I'm saying like but
that's not know listen that's amazing
I'm like I'll get this going I'll get
this done and like know what's so
amazing about that is it's so naive do
you know what do you know like do you
know how ludicrous I would I wish I was
your homie in your crew like I feel like
every crew needs somebody like me I was
like looking you'd be like bro I'm
[ __ ] talking about you know everybody
will say like you just hustle just
hustle hustle hustle and then you can
you know manage the business but that's
not it like so stupid I know so I mean
that was one of the things that I've
learned like out I got destroyed
essentially my first time around I get
destroyed basically I got out of that
experience well I
cuz I'm I rushed and I chased the
homerun versus the singles so like I
used to live in New York right now live
in New Hampshire but I used to live in
New York and like I got into this with
this dude like like we renovating
apartments it was like this massive
thing like hey I'll give you 50
apartments to renovate I'm hiring people
hiring people we're like a 12 dudes I'm
burning through like you know 15,000 a
week
but like dry account though you know
like paycheck comes in you just hate the
people because for me it's like hey I'm
gonna make it out of this
but then the guy I didn't I didn't have
a good infrastructure for like paperwork
you know a lot of that so the guy was
just like hey man as soon as he passed
the inspection with the Builder he's a
hey man I don't like your work you're
off the site and you know so that was
kind of literally just bankrupted me
right there and there's nothing could
have done about that but it's fine
because that's a huge learning
experience from that like I walked away
with that a better man but what my issue
is is
like I started a business again within
you know I licked my wounds I kind of
you know cried about it for a week
whatever like it's okay thank you that
okay but within three months I had a new
business and kind of I went being the
best versus being the biggest so like
right now we're doing bathroom Renaud's
and I just want to be the best bathroom
renovation company like online or
whatever blah blah but the negative that
I got out of it once I start reflecting
on it is like I miss almost a year of my
kid's life you know because like looking
at the pictures and stuff like on my
phone it's all work work work so like
well because I've been like AT&T family
baby business you know I don't have you
heard
there's no time machines I know but so
like my thing is right now like I love
what you say is like I do believe
personally I'm gonna live to like 120
like I'm healthy like I'm lucky again
I'm lucky so I I do feel like I'll miss
the bus you know like yeah but I think
for the next like 12 to 15 years like me
and my wife who's a rockstar to my wife
like she's my person and like literally
like she's the one I'll die next to you
know whatever oh I love those couples
were like the person like the one person
dies in 92
yeah next person dies two weeks four
weeks later that's the it's it's so we
have like this thing like let's focus on
the family right now but for the next
like 12 to 15 years because I don't
because I don't yeah I kept saying like
I would get that stuff bad
no no that's super smart I have that
itch though you know like I still have
that so I thought you should I make
sense so so audit everything else what
do you mean what else can you do besides
spend time with your family and work and
I'm being real real like meaning do you
watch TV
I do like after 8 o'clock 9 o'clock with
my wife for an hour you know and then
what are you doing at 10 o'clock a crash
and what time do you wake up it's okay
let's play let's play this me my way
this is not me I'm trying to come from a
love place that's prettier like break it
down come on I'll wake up it's tell me
the truth I want all I need all real
because if you give me fake data then we
[ __ ] wasting your time give me all
real data what time do you go to sleep
tell me the [ __ ] truth
like 11:11 what time I wake up 5:30 6:00
I mean Mike's my son will wake up and
mill in the night so I have to go in if
I'm if I'm up there houses up okay so
now break it down they wake up then what
happened what's your workday look like I
will make breakfast with them which I
love you know like so we kind of do all
of that we'll make breakfast then I
start running around the stores and yep
getting the things that I need for the
jobs and get to work and then you know
I'll clock out mentally by like 4
o'clock because I do want to be home for
dinner do you want to be home to read
the books to them like I want to do all
that so on first of all first of all a
couple things do you know how epic it is
to be a world-class father and just be a
solid businessman yeah that's um I'm
happy that's the thing like when I
texted you the question I'm like I'm the
happiest fricking person like in my life
but like there's that one like guy that
just keeps poking me and it's like the
drive inside of me that like dude go big
go big go big yeah I mean four o'clock
is like the second or third like maybe
halftime not even half-time for me but
I'm not gonna have the father you know
like moments that your dad yeah like I'm
excited Prince to be like five or six
and I get a plow truck and we freakin
start plowing you know together and like
doing all that stuff start teaching us
so it gets really good when they get
older bro there's nothin like honestly I
admire you and in a lot of ways envy you
because we don't have unlimited time
you're right there is no time machines
there's no going back to these moments I
I think we have to stop judging
ourselves you know you sound like a
world-class father with a real healthy
work-life balance like a modern-day
healthy work-life balance I'm a
workaholic that you know balances family
and extreme extremities of weekends of
vacations and and as long as there's
love overlaying
both real love not [ __ ] we're not
checking the box then no everyone's
gonna win and like that just chemicals
like there's a big part of me that
wishes there was a my DNA could clock
out at 4 o'clock but I don't that's the
thing like it's literally like being a
workaholic though so they listen now you
have to explain to me are you doing that
because you want to do that for your
wife and for your parents or your
friends to look at you and admire you
that way or are you doing it because
you're doing it for yourself it's for
myself because of I know you're making a
choice bro you should know it's for
myself like I do know that so don't like
don't don't create a fake narrative that
you like the sound of it I'm not I I do
like you know I have self like a
reflection like I I can see what I'm
like where I'm trending or whatever and
like I am grateful for it being like
mentally straight about that you know
cuz I know that I won't get that back
cuz like you know 15 years from now
whatever like I can start it and end
like a multi-billion dollar business if
I wanted to you know and where I came or
guide my kids is raise my kids I think
that's right
I know that's right I think lately
because of you know again like because
of you what's been kind of like
satisfying my itch is like the social
media stuff because I can do that then
at 9 at 8 or 9 o'clock online and like
tick tock and all that stuff so like
that then gives me a little bit of
gratification of you know I do get a
following because that's like you know
action listen I am the byproduct of a
father who I didn't see until I was 14
see he slept in the same house as manats
see him and you know in that scenario
what was your situation with your dad so
when I was 8 my dad left two United
States mm-hmm lived here for four years
to get us to get us there cuz it's cheap
you know especially back at the end you
have some debts we're two boys that has
scenarios with fathers that weren't
around and we went we went to different
directions you were affected in a way
where you're like [ __ ] that I'm not
gonna have
my kids feel that feeling and you got
deep I loved it
like I loved it and loved my dad the
most and so I've enormous comfort and if
I miss things or if I'm working and I
don't see things or if I'm not home for
dinner that I'm okay with that
mm-hmm and guess what both are okay yeah
you ready let's talk about real life one
day your kids at 22 will look you and be
like that we're the luckiest in the
world
you were always around that's amazing or
they mean looking and say dad you around
too much like I don't have drive or
ambition because even though you were
saying things you were home around all
the time and I got that from somewhere
else my kids are gonna say dad you
showed me how to live you know by living
your passion it's made me so happy
and all the good things we were doing in
different times I love that or then I
say dad you weren't around enough and I
resent you like that's real talk there's
always two sides to every coin in life
what we need to do is do the best we can
we as parents we as humans we as
children who have parents pressuring us
to go to school and things that nature
or get this job all we can do all we can
do every one of us that's on here right
now all we can do is just do the best we
can and make decisions and and then live
with those decisions and not dwell on
them we will make mistakes we will make
right decisions we do not control our
kids DNA some kids are naturally
self-confident some are naturally
insecure regardless of how you parent
them there's a lot of things that we
don't control and we need to be at ease
with that yeah I mean the fact that they
were born healthy and everything we like
we're good
you're not like totally massive people
that have horrible relationships with
their parents in the first 20 years
because they're alcoholics or
embezzlement or went to jail or hit
their mom or ran away or like yeah and
then later reconcile like like you know
don't be feel based on the parenting
side either because if you are then
you're gonna then you're gonna resent
doing that right you never sent your
kids keeping you away from your true
calling and it's not their fault it's
yours but that's how you're gonna
manifest it that's what people do that's
true and then what I'm more worried
about is that you would resent your
loved ones that you're trying to
look the part for or you're trying to
make a point to your dad or things that
nature this is important [ __ ] brother
what I can tell you right now is you
need to do what makes you happy and you
know the answer you just might be scared
of the answer or this was just what you
needed to triple down and what's going
on which by the way there is no time
machines to go back to your kids dinners
and reading books and soccer games and
proms and I think that's amazing I love
it makes me happy yeah I just want to
have those life experiences for them and
for myself you know so then we won so
part two of the lake I'm sorry this is
dragging on but like part two is like
then my generic question for everybody I
guess is like as a contractor like I
want to go the best route how do I go
about like branding myself and kind of
going about producing that scale filming
every project from coast to coast
documented get approval from the
people's homes you know to share it chop
it up put on Pinterest and Instagram
Facebook and LinkedIn Twitter at scale
YouTube podcast content content content
every one of us is immediate when the
[ __ ] is everyone gonna understand we're
all media companies and the more we
produce and the better we get at it the
more good stuff will happen and I sit
here for a [ __ ] decade say the same
[ __ ] [ __ ]
800 [ __ ] thousand times over it's the
[ __ ] answer it's so easy to believe
it I just I just need you to take 4 to 5
p.m. to film that [ __ ] because I I still
think no matter how young your kids are
five thirty is a good starting point to
yeah eleven thirty
you know like I do it on it like that's
why I think if I go niche but like a
small scale then like the media stuff
can then I have more time to do you know
because then you can kind of focus on
almost like two companies where a media
issue like situation and then like your
actual business business such a contract
there's man you have so much content
everything on tick-tock you'll get it
testimonials at scale you'd do a good
project the family lets you share the
content and then the last scene is them
saying you were [ __ ] awesome that's
why doing the right thing for customers
is always right it builds your brand
yeah we're gonna try out the zoom thing
cuz my wife she's does she does the
design
design so design-build kind of chip and
Joanna and gain love it yes stuff love
it so like I think we're trying with
today's situation again I'm trying to
get the positive out of it like hey what
if we do zoom meeting or live to help
people like hey how do I start the
battle on us I want to sneak one more in
before I'm out I love you take care then
no she ate it nothing to be sorry about
take care some are short some are long
that was interesting
bro what's up dude
what's up thank you for asking to be in
I've been waiting for this for a week
I'm happy to have you one please keep
your eyes on the road I don't need some
[ __ ] that [ __ ] alters my life a guilt
so yeah listen I wished I would have
been able to post the picture that I had
on my office a couple minutes ago but I
had to leave because of work the
pictures I had working into wine because
that's what I do I love it I sell wine I
sell wine I would have been perfect
right - you did your wine advertising
but you know point everybody put wine
tex.com put it up Justin while I talk to
Juan go ahead walk yeah so listen let me
give you a little amble of me
Cuban down here from Miami mm-hmm I came
from Pew when I was 14 and from the age
of 15 to 23 busted my ass for my dad
into another communications company or
the geek for a while as a lab and right
around the time of my 30s I had a baby
and life started switching around a
little bit and then I was like you know
what I can be in a office room anymore
for 9:00 to 5:00 9:00 to 10:00 8:00 to
11:00 whatever the time required it to
be me who with my dad and siblings we
pushed out our family business as much
as we could and went through thousand
and meet like nothing and now we're
we're still pushing forward now one of
the things that I talked to you about
was
how do you move aside from the family
business which I know it obviously and
how do you keep a balance between what
was working and I was not working
because let me give you a little more
details like for example the time that
we were working together I dad had very
good vision which as a father now I'm
thinking about opting into and that is
the two heads being better than one and
four heads can push a car faster than
just one head as long as one person the
driver and the other three are pushing
the wheels all right yeah so he's the
driver we were hoping the wheel to the
point now right now our entire family
depends on not the place welcome the
events on that business yeah that we
helped create we branched out and at
this time we're trying to come back in
after we figured out our talents there a
figure who we were but that time we were
only kids being exploited as much as my
dad thought that we could have been
exploited yes make sense honestly with
obviously we all grew that in two
different areas and the wine business
ended up being a completely random
things mucus pumps and uh on top of your
desk jump in it make a good make a good
investment and then push it forward so
wanted to ask you more or less what's
your take on how to balance your past
and family business and the flow would
you act
I would either Demark I would fully work
on my passion and build up that business
so I didn't have to rely on the
financial aspects of the family business
okay doable
of course now where do you see wine
going to wine will be drank for the rest
of time that's why God drank one of the
things that I wanted to actually
congratulations and also decide that
that you've been preparing inspirations
well and during his hard times I've seen
you to be probably one of the few people
that went at it head on
you're given a lot of a lot of content
to a lot of people a lot of work to a
lot of people that right now are doing
absolutely nothing expect from zooming
content and honestly I just wanted to
thank you for that thank you thank you
so much this conversation wasn't much to
ask you anything but more to give you a
thicker oh all that you do want I
promise you I promise you the appreciate
the appreciation I have for thank yous
is is as high as it is for the ability
to answer some questions that brings
value so I appreciate that my friend and
get back to driving another your passing
everybody you drive fast like me I like
it keep going one very do this there's
three two completely empty I don't care
I see you passing cars and it fires me
up I love passing clunkers
see you later take care what thank have
a good day you too take this off the
screen good day good day that was a
little scary I don't like the video and
driving [ __ ] it [ __ ] me up though I
think like if you don't look at the like
I don't like I'm no problem talking like
that because everyone's talking on the
phone anyway but it's the [ __ ]
looking that [ __ ] me up a little bit
nonetheless I appreciate everybody
let's do one quick one like real quick
it's one person that hung around so
perfect perfect real fast
Alex what's up bro oh [ __ ] I got a real
[ __ ] nerves real fast
don't worry it just me and you here what
are you from I'm from Pennsylvania I am
actually 20 minutes away from
Philadelphia I love it how you doing I'm
pretty bit I'm stressed I'm tired
there I don't sleep anymore I because
there's a lot of teenagers in my
generation that need mental support yeah
and are terrified yeah to go help so I'm
good at calming people down and getting
out of head spaces because I've actually
lost 10 people to suicide and I'm
terrified of it so now it's like I'm
constantly just staying awake
just call me people now so it's so real
you've had 10 friends commit suicide 10
people that I know yeah and of those
these are kids that are in your school
some of the words we're like family
members yeah and so you're stressed
because you want to provide value for
people yes and I'm also trying to make
it somewhere with BMX and I'm that's
actually why I joined here today I have
a passion for bikes I don't I don't care
what style you ride I don't care who you
are I don't care if you're just gonna
hop on a bike and go cruise if you're
gonna arrive that's great you're you're
a phenomenal person I love that I I have
a passion and I know everything I I have
15 bikes that I've built on my own I
loaned my friends bikes in my area
there's Chester right there I don't know
how much about Chester it's not a good
place at all there's shootings every day
and the group that we have started is
getting kids on BMX bikes on cruiser
bikes doing wheelies have the company
what mom what's her group called so
right there was an old group called it
one way but that stopped now so now it's
just us riding around from what was one
way one way was a bunch of kids doing
wheelies throughout Philadelphia streets
and it not the city it got everywhere
nation who's the organizer and why did
it go away
um it went away bees like the Wheeling
crew like the the scene just calmed down
and now it's like there's very few
actual BMX riders like it's still a
scene but it's small and in my area
there's no skate parks there is nothing
so it's like we just have to use the
trees that we have yep I get it so how
so I want to start my own BMX company
okay I have had this on my mind for 10
years now I've almost been riding how
old are you I'm 16
okay keep going my parents hate how much
time I put into BMX and what do they
want you to do they had to come in here
because I can relate to this like a lie
I ride just so you know let's take your
destined joiner
keep going doesn't well I mean I've
known people that started the MX
companies and then 2000 early 2000s and
that was like a hard time compared to
now like it's I mean it's it's easier
but harder because of the situation
right now but I mean if if you think
that's something you want to do just go
for it like I have a friend like started
from scratch that he started married
with his with his friend kidding yeah so
like Billy hurry my friends with Billy -
but Mike Brennan and Sean Curran are the
ones that created marry and they just
started I mean they work that animal
first and then they just started from
scratch they learned what they could
from animal and then wanted to do their
own thing and then just went off from
there and now like it's a big company
because we're not huge but like they do
well and it's like it's not impossible
I'm just saying Alex what are your I
know you're freaking out and you want
Dustin's autograph yeah because I gotta
go to this [ __ ] call what what do
your parents want you to focus on school
they want me to do school and to get a
scholarship for running cuz you're Green
runner I can sprint a 4-12 mile I don't
know what that means but sounds
impressive so why can some Island four
minutes in 12 seconds that sounds real
[ __ ] fast so just show that show that
so what's that about you hate running
I do it gifted I completely hate it the
only reason I started it was real quick
dude are you what are your parents do uh
my mom tell me I'd men's to push my next
interview for my mom finest three
billboard companies and my manager
like four is the manager of the like
tech support and engineering and stuff
for like for apartment complexes I think
got it what do parents grow up my dad
grew up in Brunel and my mom grew up
moving everywhere because her dad my
grandfather was in the Marines so she
lives in England she's lid Harris we're
parents students vary my mom has like
three degrees Mike and dad wanted to be
a lawyer but life got in the way and
what girls yep and what about siblings
my sister was take is taking college
classes right now she is a senior in
high school and she already has almost
all of her college credits completed my
brother is in seventh grade and is
taking tenth grade math while I'm in
10th grade taking eighth grade math yep
my sister all my students are like
gifted and it's just oh you [ __ ] run
like a gazelle you're [ __ ] gay the
only thing I'm gifted at is knowing that
there's a clue behind you and I can flip
that for $11.83 on ebay they're like
gifted in school and I have a processing
disability I have brain damage I have a
lot of PTSD and traumas and stuff I have
a lot I have um dyslexia and dysgraphia
yep that's awesome you know you do you
do understand that that's your strength
not [ __ ] you up right no actually I
don't have I've been let's [ __ ] Billy
you've been what um what do you say
although I don't like yeah do you not
get all the [ __ ] your teachers they
they all said I was a failure up until
this year bro my teachers thought I was
the Biggest Loser of all time have you
ever seen my [ __ ] report card no I
had straight FS me too bro
you need to find my report card you
pulling it up Dustin find it for this
man actually no let him figure it out
Alex you need to find my report card on
Instagram I posted like four times Alex
you can you cannot make school grades a
North Star okay write that down nice and
slow not a North Star you cannot have
your validation come from a game that
doesn't fit your natural strengths does
that make sense to you like your parents
want you to be good at school yes they
actually they do yes they do they
actually pushed me to staying up until
around 3:00 in the morning they're
waking up at 6:00 in the morning every
day are you [ __ ] on your parents or
are you being dead [ __ ] serious
no I'm being dead serious say they
incredibly pushed they're pushing me
pass to every single one of my mental
and physical capabilities so I can do
well in school so what we can do about
that I don't know you need to have a
real talk with them I have and what how
did those talks go basically they told
me that they know me better than I know
my own self that they only have my best
interests at heart you know that's not
true
right you know that they didn't have a
prayer of knowing not even a [ __ ]
part you didn't quote me on this to
their face they can call me they can
come see me I'm more than happy to have
a convo with them they don't have a
[ __ ] prayer of knowing you better
than you know yourself not even in the
[ __ ] universe not even the [ __ ]
universe bro they have no [ __ ] clue
what's in your [ __ ] dome I've never
opened up to any of them and my mom
claims that she's like my person to go
to when I haven't opened up to someone
since my best friend killed herself
after calling me five times bro listen
there's a of course there's a ton of
[ __ ] [ __ ] right but you have to start
having real conversations with your
parents for real for real and you need
to start pushing back on things that
aren't true that's scary of course it's
scary everything good is scary you
remember you know riding a bike is scary
I'm scared shitless I think start
writing a bike until I was nine you
[ __ ] you and Dustin or [ __ ] whiz
kids and at six were popping wheelies I
was scared as [ __ ] to skinned my knee
six I think I was actually trying a 540
over my route yeah I've no idea what the
[ __ ] you just said but I position right
now when I was nine I didn't want to
ride a bike
cuz I cuz skimming my knee sounded like
the worst [ __ ] thing of all time but
telling my parents who the [ __ ] I was
was easy as [ __ ] everything good is
scary and just so you know my parents to
this day still don't support me riding
BMX like she's always saying stop riding
your bike and I'm 35
[Laughter]
[ __ ] this show's over Alec send me an
email I want to keep talking to you but
I gotta get out of here you'll take care
of it everybody thanks for just Alex
thanks for being on there's way more
intensive we're gonna probably bring you
back on get him out of here Dustin see
Alex I know you got a tender ship and I
got to go I love everybody very much and
it was a little abrupt but uh the
[ __ ] Dustin 35 year old things [ __ ]
me up now we got work to do with Alex
but we also have some real work to do
there are their ungodly levels of people
who are hungry right now because the
food infrastructure is broken we have
started the all-in challenge Michael
Rubin the founder of fanatics outside of
Pennsylvania ironically enough all in
challenge calm Michael Rubin the founder
of fanatics is uh as a friend called me
a couple days in after you kind of
thought of it started and said I need
you stepped up along with our friend
Alan Tisch and our incredible teams at
vaynermedia and fanatics have launched
you all in challenge it has completely
exploded maybe you've seen all these
crazy things that Drake and Justin
Timberlake and Matthew McConaughey and
and come in hard and Meek Mill and on
and on and on have given away it's
exploding I've given away the ultimate
Geary be experienced come buy raffle
ticket for ten bucks to my 20 of them
for a hundred bucks I would like every
person here if they can afford $10 to go
right now to Gary Vee comm slash all-in
challenge and what I'm giving away is in
video four
it's gonna play right now if you haven't
seen the video yet you're gonna lose
your [ __ ] mind
I went [ __ ] hey I'm I hope you check
it out if you happen to uh to uh to join
it please let me know on Twitter I'm on
Twitter paying attention everything you
did play the video Dustin I am giving
away the ultimate garyvee experience how
should I go okay over the last week or
so I've been a gem with my friend
Michael Rubin and helping out on this
all-in challenge that I am accepting
right now but all-in challenge calm
please go there we are challenging some
of the greatest artists entertainers
athletes in the world to provide a
ridiculous all-time experience or one of
their most iconic items in their
collection to help raise money to help
feed the hungry during this ridiculous
time and so now I have to put up my
auction so my auction the ultimate
garyvee experience here we go I'm gonna
go off the top of the head and you can
go on all-in challenge calm to go bid on
this I am giving away okay you get to in
the course of the year you will go
garage sailing with me and film trash
talk also you can get a workout with me
and Mike Vacanti so I know a lot of you
pay attention to that part of my world
also we're gonna go to Wine Library and
do a $25,000 shopping spree that's right
I'm gonna pay my debt well I'm gonna
donate we're gonna pay my dad 25
thousand so $25,000 shopping spree at
Wine Library I will walk through the
whole store with you tell you the war
stories and you'll buy a bunch of a wine
beer liquor whatever you want food
we are going to go to a Jets game
together you're gonna tailgate with me I
never do this when I give away Jets
tickets I never let the person sit with
me so you will sit with me during the
Jets game I won't talk to you during the
game I'm completely focused but you'll
get that so the ultimate Jets experience
tailgate full game with me as well also
I'm going to give you one week play at
Vayner media so this is for you and a
plus-one by the way so the two tickets
the will be some plus ones we'll do some
just me and you depending on this
wonderful week at vaynermedia getting
consulting and business advice from team
Gary B and me for the entire week
hanging out in the pit where the show's
done you're gonna be a guest of my
podcast
we're going to do a wine dinner for you
and seven of your friends at Hunt fish
club in New York City and I'm gonna fly
you all paid plus 1 2 3 of my key notes
and we'll work on those details the
ultimate garyvee experience I hope you
bid on it I hope you get involved I hope
we raise a lot of money to help people
that need it all so what's so fun about
the Olin challenge is you get to
challenge people to be in it I am gonna
challenge all the Boehner sports
athletes I expect you in there so that
is number one number two I'm gonna go
with ooh you know what
Tim Berlin the super producer who's
completely lighting up Instagram
Timbaland the super producer I'm calling
you out and finally I got one the
Undertaker one of the great wrestlers of
all time please join the challenge
everybody go to all in challenge calm
please support this the experiences are
gonna be nuts we've been working
bleeding out of the eyeballs for the
last week putting this all together
you're gonna be blown away what you're
about to see on social media hashtag all
and challenge please check it out and
please go to your favorite celebrities
athletes and entertainers and leave
hashtag all-in challenge to get them
involved the all and challenge please
take it